hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to home improvisation the
Sweden simulator that's not what it is
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to home improvisation the
IKEA simulator which is from Sweden
that's what I was trying to think of
anyway so you this is we could wear you
in the box in the thing there's stuff
and then you got to put them together
and I'm gonna I'm gonna try not to be an
idiot here but you know how hard that is
for me and I'm gonna actually try I
don't know how to do this no how do you
I don't want to go online I don't ever
want to see my shame only people that
subscribe to me ah do I get it to go up
ah rotate you [ __ ] it didn't give me
any tutorial about this there's nothing
to this how do we there's no control
list oh come on how do i hi [ __ ] turn
yow how the [ __ ] ass I said I was gonna
oh I gotta use the keep what the [ __ ]
huh we're gonna hey what the [ __ ]
happened am i - barely even start oh oh
oh it's a cinematic view Oh ain't that a
bit who the [ __ ] is I'm playing what
who's controlling this [ __ ]
Oh what is why is it why is the camera
momentum based why what why was the
camera beam momentum based that's that's
asinine
dad that's absurd that that that's
stupid okay so this stop you serious is
this what I have to deal with oh my god
I'm going to lose my gut [ __ ] you I
don't know go away purple
oh no purple no purple wasn't me why dis
controls the camera what the fack why
would it control the camera and the
rotation of the object this is [ __ ]
stupid I'm playing that oh okay wait
they're black bears again [ __ ] ah god
dammit why who did this who the [ __ ] did
this who made this goddamn game I
haven't even gotten one peg in now is
this all this supposed to go I've never
seen like a video of assistant this
can't be right something is very wrong
obviously okay go on your side okay so
I'm gonna pick you up while I'm what why
is my mouse drifting down what not bad
oh my god okay here we go [ __ ] you
firing we're gonna die
no not yet not bad Wow trying to bind
the debugger [ __ ] I'll try to pick up
the other whoa what's upside down now
okay [ __ ] off skit one one in in and
let it go did it go this cannot be right
why am i sliding [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah back where'd it go I brought
bunnies with her it is [ __ ] thank oh
ed still deciding to Oh in na your music
selection is not helping well it's the
wrong way just just go in in in just go
in it was gonna go in it was gonna go
out I don't know how to make it go ahead
oh the frak oh this isn't right right
I should just [ __ ] restart it good
god what the [ __ ] okay I just got to
calm down because far I'm gonna burst a
blood-vessel my brain I'm gonna die okay
so obviously something is not right
options gameplay the gameplay oh it's
right there what am I doing wrong I
don't know I don't know how do I know
what to do
I don't oh [ __ ] God where to go where to
go again
where the [ __ ] did it go where the [ __ ]
did it go I don't know where the level
is now I don't know why the level is I
can't get one I cannot get one peg I
can't get one oh there you are
what the [ __ ] is that what happening
goodbye oh hello I can't I can't slow it
down what the but it would that's not my
semi house there it is there it is I was
upside down oh good I'm still holding on
to this piece of [ __ ] okay so I'm gonna
switch back the goddamn gamepad we're
gonna do this honky wonky style oh oh
now it just wants to give me the gamepad
oh oh eh oh oh that's so nice
oh oh that's so nice
it's finally nice to me oh my gudd oh my
gudd yeah ain't it that ain't it at all
ah there ah hey God why
and as much as I'd like to end it a
one-leg I know I wouldn't be forgiven
now let's do this one too but of uppy I
don't give a [ __ ] if it's off I don't
give a flying Fig I don't give a flying
kick oh that's so nice
oh it's so nice it work it do work it
works counter oh it work oh no I don't
want another box I just got this one
done there we go oh god I touched it
no I don't want to players god damn it
just stop moving stop moving stop moving
stop it okay up you shall rise okay
that's it work
so how that's supposed to work I don't
know you don't know okay
yeah wait wait wait ah ah okay oh I did
it wrong ah [ __ ] [ __ ] ah oh oh ah yes
no but also yes yes yes and I saw the
dotted let they're young footballer oh I
thought this was gonna be a game where
you know you go ah ah man I can't get it
but it looks funny am i right my god
what the fighting to go to the garage I
don't know how to zoom out I can get out
of no one wants you err alright fine
oh man I don't know I was actually when
I came into this game I was ready to
actually try I was ready to actually
make a thing like oh I know probably
most people just dick around but I'm
gonna try to actually do it back I don't
know what these pieces are I don't know
where they go I don't know anything
about this
this became a lot less fun when I
discovered that it hates me when I
discovered that everything in the
universe hates me
that's when I stopped having fun hahaha
get the [ __ ] out of here get deaf [ __ ]
out it I don't see ya get out of there
you to Pillar
you do you sure you also other cushion
why are you doing anything sure you're
the same as them supposed to be a bench
right yeah
fly a flagon I forget was you a flake it
was gravely a freak well gavage ah I
know I know what that is okay I know
ah I do know okay I know I know I get it
now okay so these have yeah those have
four connectors okay so that's very
important okay you gotta be yeah that's
the stuff okay so yes this is a clue
here as to move yeah okay
yeah lineup the shadow use the shadow as
my guiding boot yeah okay yes yes yes
okay all right okay
return of the man yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna build this [ __ ]
I'm gonna build it yeah I'm gonna build
it it's gonna be great
just like that okay a little off I could
have done that better out admittedly I
could have done that a lot better I am
okay all right okay all right okay all
right okay
Oh
okay all right okay chemists yeah we're
getting somewhere
we're getting somewhere good or
somewhere very not good I don't care
which at this point as long as we get
somewhere okay I'm getting better at it
which is a scary thought but it's what's
happening but yeah little off but that's
okay the other ones are equally as
little off okay so then what I'll need
to do is I'll need to put one of these
on first okay there we go and then onto
both of these I said both of those I
said both of those young lady at wha-at
well ha yeah okay so now this one
doesn't need to do much of anything it
just needs to go oh it needs to go all
right it needs to go right in there
yeah okay okay one more glorious piece
okay here we go
oh god is this gonna it's gonna do
properly
cool yeah oh yes yeah I have a table I
can't believe it I did it oh no don't
you freaking dare be douchey on me I am
the one who douches boink oh it's it's
lovely it's lovely what was it called
again
a lovely request no get it out here I
don't want to do it I'm done okay so
that's all for home improvisation now
that I actually figured out the controls
I know how to play and we don't need to
visit this ever again right guys let me
know what you think in the comments
below and thank you everybody so much
for watching I'm gonna go lay down and
pet chica and try to
he's dressed yes I can thanks again and
as always I'll see in the next video
please
how about living in the moon